[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie dabei sind für den sport
im studio ist rudi cerne hallo show
guten abend und auf diese themen blicken
wir heute
immer mehr angriffe auf das belagerte
mario pohl in limberg sterben nach
russischen raketen beschuss mindestens
sieben menschen
listeriose keime auf gurkenscheiben ein
toter nach gravierenden hygienemängeln
in einem südhessischen gemüse betrieb
und gedenken an groß sprengung auf
helgoland vor 75 jahren zündeten die
briten tausende tonnen munition um die
militärischen anlagen zu zerstören
das russische militär hat offenbar seine
luftangriffe auf große städte in der
ukraine verstärkt auch mehren sich die
anzeichen dass die großoffensive ganz im
osten beginnen könnte angesichts der
kämpfe kritisiert vitali klitschko
bürgermeister der hauptstadt kiew
deutschland wegen zögerlicher
waffenlieferungen er könne diese debatte
nicht verstehen so klitschko vor allem
in der belagerten strategisch wichtigen
hafenstadt mario pohl hat es bereits
zahlreiche opfer gegeben ein bericht von
axel com hat
auch in mario pohl gehen sie noch
spazieren mit freunden der familie mit
dem hund doch es fällt auf die blicke
gehen eher auf den boden nicht rechts
nicht links denn das grauen ist
allgegenwärtig in der ruinenstadt
leichen auch von kindern säumen die
straßen eine würdige grabstätte und sei
sie noch so provisorisch ist selten
heftig umkämpft bleibt das riesige
stahlwerke verschanzt haben sich hier
die reste der ukrainischen truppen und
wohl auch eine größere zahl zivilisten
frauen kinder babys sollen
den pro-russischen angreifern hat sich
dieser franzose angeschlossen sein motiv
war unklar
da ist ein kleiner bereich um die fabrik
hier hat sich der feind in den kellern
versteckten die scheibe rein und die
burgen offensive vor aber vorher wird
die artilleriefeuer
diese drohnen aufnahmen sollen einblick
in die ukrainische gegenwehr in mario
pohl geben veröffentlicht hat sie am
nachmittag die nationalistische aus
afrika de einen vorstoß der russin in
einem fahrzeugkonvoi wird offenbar
erfolgreich zurückgeschlagen
auch nico 300 kilometer nordwestlich war
wie der ziel russische angriffe raus aus
der stadt heißt es jetzt für hunderte
verletzte zivilisten zu unsicher hier
und sie wollen platz schaffen in den
krankenhäusern denn wenn der russische
stürmer auf den don was kommt werden sie
wohl jedes bett brauchen für die
verwundeten soldaten
tote und verletzte gibt es heute auch
wieder ganz im westen des landes in
lemberg nahe der grenze zu polen fünf
raketen schlagen ein getroffen wurden
neben militärischen objekten auch ein
hotel und eine werkstatt der angriff
soll wohl auch dieses zeichen senden
sicherheit gibt es in keiner stadt und
keinem ort des landes
mehr als 1100 deutsche ärztinnen und
ärzte haben sich bereit erklärt zu
helfen sie wollen entweder in der
ukraine selbst oder in einem
nachbarstaat kranke und verletzte
behandeln so die bundesärztekammer viele
freiwillige aus allen bereichen hessen
schon jetzt die menschen vor ort in der
ukraine
unser reporter dominic löschmeister hat
eine gruppe getroffen die zivilistinnen
und zivilisten aus der stadt los war im
osten des landes retten konnte
sie verladen lebensmittel in den alten
linienbus in kiel kochen essen für die
menschen die sie retten wollen
ralf kubon von der deutschen
hilfsorganisation eines will
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ost ukraine
rausholen geplant ist die evakuierung
eines dorfs wir haben kontakt man da vor
ort
dass es sehr nah an der kampfzone und
man rechnet damit dass die kampfzone
auch diesen ort erreichen wird
530 kilometer geht es richtung ost
ukraine auch eine kurze panne hält sie
nicht auf zwölf stunden später erreichen
sie los so war jetzt muss es schnell
gehen hilfsgüter ausladen jederzeit
könnte es beschuss geben nur schweren
herzens verlässt jewgenia deren
heimatort ihre eltern wollen bleiben
wir gehen weil die kinder leiden und
seinen kampfflugzeuge fliegen es gibt
explosionen
es ist einfach hoffnungslos ich mache
mir sorgen um meine eltern
mitnehmen können sie nur einen kleinen
koffer ein paar persönliche dinge die
menschen hier haben eine traumatische
zeit hinter sich
meine kinder und enkelkinder sind
bereits geflohen sind jetzt den solheim
bei köln ich war allein ihre ich bin
schullehrer sind ich kann keine kinder
mehr unterrichten ich habe mich
entschieden zu gehen hatte die hälfte
ist geschafft für rolf kubon den
deutschen helfer er bringt die menschen
raus aus der ost ukraine
morgen wollen sie in polen ankommen
wenn sie geflüchteten weiter helfen
wollen können sie geld spenden zum
beispiel dem aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
im zeichen des ukraine krieges haben in
den letzten tagen tausende menschen in
deutschland an ostermärschen
teilgenommen so auch heute etwa am
fliegerhorst büchel in der eifel wo die
friedensbewegung die letzten in
deutschland stationierten atomwaffen
vermutet
bundesweit fanden über die ostertage in
mehr als 120 städten aktionen für
frieden und abrüstung statt ihre
forderung ein waffenstillstand und ein
ende des
zu corona nach dem jüngsten ausbruch in
der chinesischen millionenmetropole
shanghai haben die behörden erstmals
drei todesfälle gemeldet es soll sich um
ältere vor erkrankte handeln in china
werden täglich mehr als 20.000 menschen
positiv auf das virus getestet fast alle
davon in shanghai die hafenstadt ist
seit ende märz weitgehend im lotto die
meisten der rund 26 millionen menschen
in shanghai dürfen ihre wohnungen nicht
verlassen
in deutschland steht
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach in
der kritik weil er vor einer möglichen
zitat killer variante des corona wie
russland der begriff sei
unwissenschaftlich und führe zu nichts
als verunsicherung in der bevölkerung
sagte der virologe schmidt chanasit der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
grünen-bundestagsfraktion von notz
twitterte erhalte vage prognosen zu der
möglichkeit der entstehung einer
absoluten killer variante für wirklich
wenig hilfreich
in hessen sorgt ein neuer
lebensmittelskandal für schlagzeilen ein
mensch starb im krankenhaus nach dem
verzehr von verkeimten gurkenscheiben
drei weitere personen mussten behandelt
werden
ausgangspunkt war ein gemüse betrieb in
südhessen der wegen gravierender
hygienemängel inzwischen beschlossen ist
markus wolsiffer berichtet von schimmel
und ratten code ist die rede die
hygienischen zustände bei der firma aus
in gernsheim offenbar katastrophal von
hier aus lieferte der betrieb die mit
listerien belasteten gurken auch an
krankenhäuser in offenbach musste
deshalb wohl ein mensch sterben der
gemüsebetriebs sei auch wegen der
pandemie zu selten kontrolliert worden
zuletzt 2009 10 konnte landrat ein lasst
mich geärgert hat ihn heute noch ärgert
und das sage ich auch in dieser in
dieser offenheit ist was von diesem von
diesen kontrollen
verzögerungen und von denen nicht
ausgeführten kontrollen in den täglichen
schon fix gründen schon fix corona mit
dem gesundheitsbereich nicht ein
einziges mal die rede gewesen ist es ist
nicht der erste lebensmittelskandal in
hessen auch bei will bewusst wurden 2009
10 gefährliche bakterien gefunden die
kontrollen damals wie heute viel zu
lasch
natürlich haben die kreise zunächst die
erste verantwortung aber sie sind
unterfinanziert chronisch
unterfinanziert seit jahren und deswegen
kommt das raus was bei rausgekommen ist
nämlich zu wenig personal und teilweise
gar keine kontrollen die zuständige
ministerin priska hinz weist die kritik
zurück im aktuellen fall habe ihr
ministerium gemeinsam mit der task force
lebensmittelsicherheit sofort gehandelt
und die aufklärung in die wege geleitet
infolge der stringenten ausbruchs
ermittlungen durch die tf konnte ein
lebensmittel bedingter
krankheitsausbruch frühzeitig erkannt
und weitere infektionen verhindert
werden der obst und gemüse betrieb ist
mittlerweile geschlossen die
aufarbeitung des skandals hat gerade
erst begonnen
genau 75 jahre ist es her da dröhnte
eine gewaltige explosion über die
nordsee so auf dem 60 kilometer
entfernten festland war sie zu hören
big ben die briten die operation auf der
hochseeinsel helgoland die zu diesem
zeitpunkt unbewohnt war mit
6700 tonnen munition sollten die
militärischen anlagen zerstört werden
die gewaltige sprengung hat das gesicht
der insel verändert bis heute dort kann
die
18 april
ein knopfdruck ist sie aus die größte
nicht nukleare sprengung der geschichte
fast 7000 tonnen sprengstoff explodieren
auf der evakuierten insel helga die
briten wollen alle militärischen anlagen
aus der nazi zeit zerstören die
helgoländer waren zu dieser zeit auf dem
festland untergebracht unter ihnen
damals elf jahre alte olaf ohlsen er
verfolgt das geschehen von cuxhaven aus
das war kein großer
scheine vor sprengung war einmal steht
der große rausch
luft wir wussten heldin ist gesprengt
75 jahre ist das jetzt die helgoländer
erinnerten heute mit einem
gedenkgottesdienst an den sogenannten
big ben der bis heute seine spuren
hinterlassen hat auf deutschlands
einziger hochseeinsel
wir haben heute wenn wir bauvorhaben
haben haben wir immer noch kampfmittel
bomben große bomben in den böden in der
erde und ja dass man das macht das immer
noch mal wieder so wach was damals
passiert sein kann man kann sich das ja
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen tiefe
wunden grad erzeugen bis heute von
dieser zeit aber die insel steht es gibt
zeitzeugenberichte nachdem einige
britische offiziere gesagt haben sollen
blödes bloody eiland ab aber ich glaube
nicht also das ziel war wirklich nur die
beseitigung militärischen anlagen vor
allem die helgoländer rinnen helgoländer
hatten angst also können wir jemals auf
unserer insel wieder zurück auf diesen
tag mussten die helgoländer noch lange
warten fast fünf jahre bis zum ersten
märz
und jetzt gehen wir zum sport endspurt
in der fußball bundesliga wo genau
spannender kampf um die internationalen
plätze zum abschluss des 30 spieltages
der fußball-bundesliga hat rb leipzig im
kampf um einen
champions-league-startplatz einen
wichtigen erfolg verbucht die mannschaft
von domenico tedesco gewann das direkte
duell bei bayer leverkusen mit 1 zu 0
leverkusen versucht alles den ball ins
tor zu bekommen aber selbst torjäger
schick gelingt die überquerung der
torlinie nur ganz allein auch als
vorbereiter zeigt patrick vollen einsatz
doch wen immer er in szene setzt der
führungstreffer will leverkusen einfach
nicht gelingen
nach einwechslung von konko zur zweiten
hälfte kommt leipzig besser ins spiel
der franzose geht hier zu boden kein
elfmeter opfern schuss dann am pfosten
trainer today's kogge fällt die
steigerung seine entscheidungen kongo zu
bringen zahlt sich in der 70 minute aus
der franzose auch super sly und der
umgang mit dem 1 0 siegtreffer seinen
schuss noch leicht abgefälscht durch ta
leipzig bringt über leverkusen hinweg
auf rang drei
und durch leverkusens niederlage ist
borussia dortmund sicher für die
champions league qualifiziert leipzig
seit 14 pflichtspielen ungeschlagen am
mittwoch das dfb-pokal-halbfinale gegen
union berlin und die berliner sind in
prächtiger form besiegen eintracht
frankfurt mit 2 zu 0 hoffenheim und der
abgeschlagene tabellenletzte greuther
fürth trennten sich torlos alle spiele
alle tore können sie unter zdf heute.de
und in der heute anschauen
tokio olympiasiegerin perry skeptiker
und evans chips haben beim boston
marathon für kenianische erfolge gesorgt
beim ältesten stadtmarathon der welt
setzte sich der 33 jahre alte kate in
zwei stunden 6 minuten 51 sekunden durch
das war die drittbeste siegerzeit in der
125 jährigen geschichte des rennens
bei den frauen erzielte theresa
tschitscherin zwei stunden 21 01
ebenfalls die drittbeste zeit einer
sieger
bei strahlendem sonnenschein das war
wohl ein gutes maskottchen ruhe ganz
wichtig im sport wird denn was könnte
das stichwort da schauen wir jetzt noch
drauf auf ein besonderes jubiläum heute
in münchen 50 jahre dackel weil die das
erste offizielle olympia maskottchen von
1972 im traditionellen bayrischen gewand
oder doch lieber im strickpulli modell
weil die und ebenfalls auf dem programm
was sportliches der dackel parcours was
bei den einen ganz gut klappte gelang
bei den anderen eher weniger
und jetzt kann ich ihnen schon mal zum
wetter für morgen verraten es scheint
wieder oft die sonne und es wird mild
nur ganz im osten sind einige schauer
unterwegs den genauen blick aufs wetter
kriegen sie gleich von katja horneffer
bettina schausten begrüßt sie zum heute
journal um 21.45 bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend vom schnee im norwegischen
gebirge bis zum schnee in den alpen sah
der satellit heute nur wenige wolken im
osten gab es dagegen einige wolken und
die breiten sich im laufe der nacht
etwas weiter ins landesinnere aus die
temperaturen sinken auf sechs grad an
der nordsee oder auch am niederrhein bis
minus zwei grad am alpenrand
das west-ost-gefälle bei den
temperaturen bleibt uns auch morgen über
tag erhalten im westen wird es mild mit
15 bis 20 grad im osten sind es dagegen
nur 7 bis 14 grad dort gibt's dichtere
wolken und in ostsachsen und in
ostbayern reicht auch für einige
regenschauer oder graupelschauer sonst
scheint die sonne und bei einem uv-index
von vier oder fünf können sie
ungeschützt bereits nach 20 bis 30
minuten einen sonnenbrand bekommen in
den nächsten tagen geht es mit ruhigem
frühlingswetter weiter und bis freitag
wird es sogar ein kleines bisschen
melder genannt